la france comptabilise les suicides par
profession ce qui permet d'avoir une
image plus exacte de la réalité et cette
réalité est inquiétante
près de deux suicides d'agriculteurs par
jour pour alerter ses concitoyens sur le
mal être qui règne dans les campagnes un
conseiller municipal d'une petite ville
française est parti en croisade
[Musique]
patrick morel marche
depuis 2016 il a parcouru 2000 km à pied
à travers la france en 2008 chez mon
meilleur ami christian qui s'est
suicidée pas très loin d'ici ou au
chômage
qu'est ce que c'est qui c'est passé pour
partir si vite
donc j'ai décidé de prendre mon bâton de
pèlerin et d'aller de ferme en ferme
pour discuter avec les agriculteurs
bonjour tout le monde alors comment
allez vous ce qu'il découvre le
bouleverse
aujourd'hui on peut plus parler de
suicide je veux plus entendre dans ce
terme ça s'appelle pas un suicide ça
s'appelle un génocide
c'est pire que ce à quoi je m'attendais
en 2015 il ya eu six en cinq
agriculteurs qui se sont suicidés 605
agriculteurs ça fait 1,2 6,7 par jour
c'est énorme c'est énorme
presque deux agriculteurs par jour
au fil des discussions patrick man ray
constate la réalité derrière les
chiffres
en trois semaines demain que 1200 euros
le manque de rythme il est tout simple
routine forcément robin smig c'est il me
sera bouffé
manque de revenus
difficulté à faire vivre sa famille
il ya 30 % des agriculteurs et qui sont
à vos prix à 300 euros par mois
c'est lamentable c'est pas normal
j'ai surtout peur de laisser tout tomber
de perdre l'exploitation ça fait six
générations que c'est là j'aimerais pas
que ce soit mon tour de la coulée
il ya 450 mille agriculteurs en france
mais il ya bien 150 mille agriculteurs
qui n'arrive plus il ya l'autre moitié
arrive à gagner un petit peu d'argent et
le premier tiers s'en sortent à peu près
bien pour pas dire bien quand même mais
c'est pas non plus la panacée
[Musique]
une dette qui s'accumule s'ajoute la
pression des créanciers
puis il ya ces produits venus d'ailleurs
vendus à moindre coût qui respecte
d'autres véhicules
[Musique]
il n'y a pas besoin d'aller si loin mais
les cannois l'espagne ou l'italie
ils ont des produits qu'ils utilisent
que nous nous intéresse nous interdisons
donc ça fait une concurrence déloyale a
forcément
les visites se poursuivent au hasard de
la route quel âge et âge peut-il un
ouvrier c'est toujours non loin lors on
n'a même pas moi le constat se confirme
aux jeunes troupeau qui trop petit pour
vivre que de ça parce que les gens
mangent de moins bonnes de viande de
boeuf
patrick morin constate l'arrivée d'un
autre phénomène il faut que les
écologistes et les environnementalistes
arrête la persécution
parce que c'est plus possible de vivre
ça
depuis quelques années les paysans font
face à des intrusions et à des attaques
de groupes d'extrémistes vegan et des
antispécistes certains font brûler ferme
et certains se font cambrioler y en a
qui se font même agressé et je sais pas
je ne sais pas quand c'est que ça va
s'arrêter
ça fait vingt trente ans quoique on a
laissé nos agriculteurs de côté et puis
maintenant il ya un certain ras-le-bol
qui s'installe et je crois que il
commence à y avoir le feu dans nos
campagnes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui si tu veux les choses vont
trop loin qu on laisse mourir du paysan
dans la plus grande impunité
mais quel est donc ce pays où l'on vit
contre lyon
pourtant il existe de nombreux services
pour venir en aide aux agriculteurs en
france
mais pour patrick morel c'est nettement
insuffisant
le gouvernement doit prendre les choses
en main nue mur qui nous le fort patrick
morin prépare un projet de loi qu'il va
soumettre au président emmanuel macron
qu'il a rencontré au salon de
l'agriculture de paris en février 2019
faut qu'on pense qu'on peut faire pour
accompagner les familles si je prends le
point il va regarder comment on fait
cette transformation pour que les gens
puissent ils dignes voilà le projet de
loi ambitieux qui bouscule les habitudes
de pouvoir leur payer réellement le prix
de revient d'un produit interdit en
france de vendre moins cher que ceux qui
n'ont revient ensuite il faut que l'on
puisse aider nos agriculteurs à à vendre
leurs produits directement prioriser
l'achat local sensibiliser la population
à acheter français patrick murray s'est
trouvé des alliés dans sa quête dont le
maire de marmande
il faut sortir l'agriculture de tous les
accords internationaux
parce que maintenir l'agriculture dans
des accords qui concernent de temps en
temps des voitures de temps en temps des
produits manufacturés de temps en temps
de l'énergie de temps en temps qui sait
quoi on en arrive aujourd'hui à détruire
des filières qui concerne l'alimentation
humaine
en compensation de filières qui sont
soient industrielles / manufacturière et
et qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
sortir l'agriculture de toutes les
ententes internationales protéger
l'agriculture au même titre que le
secteur de la culture
c'est un virage majeur que patrick morin
veut voir instaurée pendant ce temps de
ce côté ci de l'atlantique
les producteurs font aussi face aux
mêmes sources de stress
ottawa a multiplié les accords
internationaux au cours des dernières
années est un autre phénomène fait son
entrée on n'a rien
c'est beaucoup plus qu'un régime
alimentaire il s'assoit pierrette
desrosiers et psychologues
ce soir elle rencontre des producteurs
porcins et laitier à sainte marie bos je
pense qu'un des prochaines menace ce
sera certainement la montée de ce qu'on
appelle des activistes au militantisme
min 36 ans fait les big n qui milite
pour l'arrêt complet de l'élevage
dernièrement ils ont mené les coups
d'éclat dans des restaurants et dans des
fermes des vidéos ont rapidement été
mise en ligne et vous par des milliers
de personnes
un pro du tarn écrivait pierre faisait
aujourd'hui mon fils qui va prendre la
relève devra accepter aussi de se faire
traiter de viol arrêtent de croire mais
on touche aux carmes heinz qu'on appelle
à l'identité propre de thé la fierté que
toi de faire tomber si ces domaines une
attaque à l'intégrité pyschologique il
ya les organisations elle leur apprend à
répondre à ces attaques sur les réseaux
sociaux à rectifier les fausses
informations qui circulent
bref à réagir je pense que ça va devoir
passer par beaucoup de sensibilisation
d'éducation et que comme société on
n'accepte pas si on n'accepte pas que
notre producteur soit
traiter comme ça il faut rétablir cette
communication le on a avec les
consommateurs et citoyens et c'est comme
ça qu'on envoie y arriver martin caron
est porteur du dossier sur la détresse
psychologique des agriculteurs à lui pea
selon lui il faut réconcilier la
population avec l'agriculture valoriser
la profession
moi je pense qu'on pourra pas aider
mener la détresse mais on travaille
présentement sur un équilibre de vie
je crois qu'on a mis en avant plaint
beaucoup les entreprises agricoles mais
je pense qu'on est rendu de merde les
personnes des personnes avant toute
chose parce que la première est actif au
niveau des entreprises
selligent donc martin caron et schiste
ottawa doit faire sa part
malheureusement il ya des produits qui
sont rentrés de dos pays qui rompt pas
des mêmes standards de qualité et je
sentais tu reconnais là dessus je pense
qu'il faut mettre la pression au niveau
du gouvernement fédéral pour ramener la
réciprocité des règles et déjà on n'a
qu'à discuter avec des producteurs pour
constater qu'à peu près tous connaissent
des agriculteurs qui ont mis fin à leurs
jours
parfois c'était des leaders dans leur
communauté
aucun producteur n'est à l'abri est ce
que vous vous considérez guéri mais dont
je me considère pas guéri
hier encore ça m'arrive l'occasion hier
encore il ratera musique le pack a pas
de travail
[Musique]
daniel barry complète une formation
d'opérateur de camions lourds
ça lui permettra de s'évader un peu et
de laisser plus de place à sa relève
sans pour autant abandonner
l'agriculture pierre gagnier a d'autres
projets en tête
mais il sait maintenant s'arrêter
mélissa est là pour le lui rappeler
geneviève racine poursuit sa route
encore aujourd'hui des producteurs lui
parle de leur détresse
ce qu'elle souhaite c'est qu'on
multiplie les services dead patrick
morin lui continue de marcher seul dans
l'espoir de faire bouger les choses mais
il le sait son combat sera long
[Musique]